did amber have a contract for aquaman
one
yes
how much was she paid for aquaman one
aquaman won she was paid two million
dollars okay and did that same contract
uh provide for if she was in aquaman two
i'm sorry i apologize aquaman one i
believe she got one million dollars
aquaman two she was supposed to get two
million dollars i apologize the numbers
there were a lot of numbers in that one
contract so aquaman won it was one
million all command two is gonna be two
million
all right now based on your experience
uh and knowledge in the industry
how much would amber hurt have been able
to negotiate uh her contract but for the
deb waldman statements
for aquaman too i'm asking right well as
you can see from mr mimo's contract that
went up exponentially up to 15 million
dollars uh miss heard i don't know if
she would have gotten 15 million dollars
for the movie but she certainly could
have increased it by one or two million
dollars or even doubled it so if it was
two it could have been four
or even five or six depending on the
enthusiasm if had it just rolled from
aquaman one to aquaman two without any
of this
negativity that was created by the
walmart the deb waldman statements and
we've heard from mr banya
did you review mr banya's q score
analysis regarding the comparables you
used yes i did and what if any opinions
have you formed and reviewing mr banya's
analysis regarding the comparables you
selected so mr bani looked at
calendar years to assess so what
happened in december of you know
2017 or 18 or 19 what happened in june
what happened in a very specific time
frame
which works on some statistical analysis
but when you're talking about actors and
their relationships to q scores q scores
are related to the actors viability in
the consumer's
mind if you will how well known or how
much they're coming up in conversation
and so mr benny did not look at time
periods of the actors that i compare
them with to the film when it came out
so like right after the success of their
big film what was their q score but
moreover he just
looked at them in a year range so
it doesn't coincide from actor to actor
just because you look at it over time
you have to look at it specifically
after each of those individuals
box office success with a particular
film you look at the q score higher low
during that and then you look at how low
it drops
say a couple months afterwards and then
if it comes back up if they have another
film or another event that brings them
into the
the limelight again so it's not about
time it's related to a specific activity
or event and he did not do that what did
your comparison show in terms of films
that those actors had been in since
their breakout roles
i'm talking about the comparables
in terms of their
i'm not quite sure i understand um well
what
what happened with these other actors
after they had their
stories unrelated to q scores right
right okay sorry so all those actors
careers the ones i mentioned they all
either were a steady rise or even a
meteoric rise in in terms of where their
career went after their stars born
moment then they got some other good
films and maybe they got another film
that performed extremely well so it was
a range but they all were on an upward
trajectory without a doubt
and what does this mean for amber
with a reason i mean the way that the
the kind of industry works is usually
unless there is an uh forced major or
some really negative event
her career should have followed that
same upward swing and in about the same
time frame it give or take six months to
a year
but you it would be very reasonable to
to believe that her career would have
been on an upward trajectory
within the range
of those other actors so over the course
of five years it's very reasonable to
consider that she would have been in at
least one film a year
at a minimum of four million dollars
because that's
what her president would have been had
she renegotiated and it's important to
note that in her inner justice league
contract
had their if there is a aquaman
three her price is set at four million
dollars so it's very reasonable to
assume
and to believe
that
if she did a film a year
for five years at a minimum of four
million a year without any negotiation
which probably would have happened but
let's just say that baseline that would
be another 20 million dollars over that
time frame so combining all of these
opinions and calculations that you've
had what if any range are the losses you
are estimating for amber heard but for
the deb waldman statements
right so again it's really important
that i looked at and and hopefully you
understand this that it's over time
right so let's just say a minimum of
five years that we're going to talk
about these losses and it could be more
but at minimum if you look at the
film
the television
and the endorsement contracts
it's very likely that ms heard should
have earned between 45 and 50 million
dollars over that time period